fin 2010 8 3 ans mais continue sa montée
en gamme déjà que le pétain prouve la
dent vraiment envoyer du bois là avec
les mecs 20 procès aujourd'hui on va
parler d'un smartphone qui met une
petite claque qui met même une grande
claque fin 2018 c'est un smartphone qui
est vraiment vraiment excellent il est
là il est là il est beau il est chaud
c'est le mail d'un pro et je vous en
parle parce que ce mec 20 pro il envoie
du bois
franchement il envoie du bois il va très
loin pour un smartphone de fin 2018
il a quasiment tout il a énormément de
points positifs il a aussi quelques
petits trucs négatifs mais bon
franchement c'est pas grand chose c'est
quasiment un sans faute
c'est vraiment une très belle réussite
de la part de huawei on parle pas du
tout sur un produit comme le mec des
impros par hasard quand on va sur un
smartphone comme celui là c'est qu'on
cherche vraiment quelque chose d'être
très exigeant qui va très loin voire
même beaucoup plus loin que la confiance
parce que ce smartphone il a quelque
chose de spécial déjà en terme de design
il est franchement incroyable
extrêmement bien réussi les finitions
sont vraiment magnifiques
alors il ya ceux qui n'aimeront pas
l'encoche une encoche et là vous pourrez
pas y couper
c'est un coach un vrai sens c'est une
reconnaissance de votre visage en trois
dimensions pour déverrouiller en un tour
de main si vous montrez jeu mais en face
ça puis c'est instantané
c'est vraiment extrêmement rapide ça
fonctionne super bien mais pour
déverrouiller il ya aussi une autre
solution on peut complètement dérouillée
grâce au capteur d'empreintes digitales
qui est positionné ici et qui marche
extrêmement bien
alors ça c'est une nouveauté de cette
année on l'a également sur le wan plus
ce système qui est là ça fonctionne
extrêmement bien à la différence là
dessus vous avez un petit effet de vague
sur l'écran qui donne un effet de
profondeur alors sans ventes +6 t ça
vous fait un côté éclaire électrique
ça marche très bien restons dans le
design il ya donc cette fameuse encoches
on aime ou on n'aime pas il ya un écran
qui est assez incroyable avec des bords
complètement incurvé alors ce design
vous dira peut-être quelque chose il
n'est pas sans rappeler un peu le design
de samsung très inspiré mais qui
franchement fonctionne extrêmement bien
on est une petite bande noire en bas en
haut c'est pas énorme légère sur les
côtés les extrêmement bien profilée
petit bouton rouge âge qu'on sait très
très beau bouton pour l'allumer pour
l'état un petit bouton de volume en bas
vous avez votre tiroir de cartes sim de
l'usb clipser sur l'autre côté vous
n'avez absolument rien et sur le haut
ici vous avez de l'infrarouge
autant dire que le design est
franchement épuré et si vous regardez la
face arrière vous avez le triple capteur
photo les cas sans vent pareil parce que
c'est aussi un très très très gros point
fort de smartphones le logo huawei la
certification européenne vraiment très
très bien réussi là dessus franchement
c'est un sans faute par contre je lui
reproche un petit quelque chose c'est
que je trouve assez glissant de par les
matières qui ont été choisis le dos en
verre je trouve un peu glissant et
franchement à chaque fois j'ai peur j'ai
échappé que ça m'arrivait une fois
heureusement il s'est rien passé mais ça
c'est un peu le point qui me fait un peu
peur smartphone comme celui là même s'il
est vraiment magnifique je vous
conseille réellement de mettre une coque
de protection
et si vous regardez très près ya des
petites bandes de finition sont vraiment
incroyables
il ya vraiment super boulot a été fait
là dessus fin 2018 huawei continue sa
montée en gamme déjà que le pétain
prouve elle a donc vraiment envoyer du
bois là avec le mec 20 procès on atteint
des sommets c'est franchement assez
incroyable autre point qui est vraiment
énorme c'est l'écran vous avez un écran
oled quad hd 3120 par 1440 pixels 6,39
de diagonale à 538 pixels par pouce
c'est un écran qui extrêmement lumineux
là je le pousse à fond vous pouvez
complètement venir paramétrer les
couleurs de l'écran si vous n'avez pas
commettre une tonalité un peu plus
naturelle qui va le rendre légèrement
plus jeune vous pouvez modifier la
couleur là et tire un petit peu sur le
bleu très très léger bleus pouvait
corriger
hop on va tirer un peu plus en jaune
très léger comme ça vous faites vraiment
ce que vous voulez vous pouvez vraiment
aller loin grâce à la surcouche maison
qui est vraiment très très bien cet
écran incurvé et franchement magnifique
lorsque vous naviguez il ya vraiment un
énorme confort moi je suis vraiment très
très fan la finition est vraiment
vraiment vraiment sublime et très très
bien réussi de ce côté là également
design de ouf écran de ouf et
performance de ouf parce que vous avez
dessus un kirin 980 qui le premier saute
android est gravé en 7 nanomètres et
franchement ce qu'irene 980 il envoie du
bois j'étais à la présentation lorsque
richard youla présenté à l'ifa à berlin
alors l'intérêt du keirin 980 c'est quoi
c'est déjà adopté
lisez complètement les performances de
données les performances à la machine
quand on en a réellement besoin et quand
il n'ya pas besoin on y va mollo mollo
ce qui permet d'avoir déjà une machine
qui va être très puissante de gagner
vraiment en autonomie et d'aller
beaucoup plus loin d'aller beaucoup plus
loin en terme de calcul c'est à dire que
lorsqu'on va par exemple on va faire une
photo de vous votre smartphone va
complètement vous des tours et au pixel
près pour aller beaucoup plus loin en
termes de photos beaucoup plus loin en
terme de vidéo
kirin 980 +6 jega drame ça nous donne un
résultat sur en tout ou de 271 1227 en
tout cas ça c'est le résultat de mon
test parce que si vous allez sur en tout
ils vous donnent le meilleur vin pro en
première position avec un résultat 2 309
1628 c'est quand même un peu plus que ce
que j'ai trouvé moi en deuxième position
vous avez le rock faune de asus est en
troisième position vous avez le one + 6
à 2 192 1007 au niveau du résultat pour
moi le one + 6 t qui est à droite un
score qui est un peu plus élevé que le
match d'impro sur la gauche mais bon
c'est zoug globalement a pas grand chose
à mon ex qui tirerait ce qui tire bien
mais voilà on en parle plus pour du pib
j'ai en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que c'est extrêmement fluide ça marche
très très bien ça permet vraiment de
s'amuser et de faire tout ce qu'on veut
avec ça c'est hyper hyper cool puisqu il
dans la partie multimédia on va mettre à
regarder un petit peu ce qui a en termes
de visionnage de vidéos et là dessus
aussi l'écran oled est complètement
hallucinant c'est un vrai régal pour le
multimédia c'est vraiment d'écran qui
est hyper hyper cool
alors vous avez effectivement cette
petite encoche là il y en a qui n'aiment
pas qu'ils pensent que ça défigure ce
qui est génial c'est fait d'avoir un
écran incurvé sur l'eau et sur le bas ça
donne vraiment une sensation d'immersion
qui est vraiment super super super
rebelle
à côté de ça ce qui est vraiment cool
c'est le son et le qualité sonore qui
est bien il ya du volume
vous avez un haut parleur qui situe ici
au niveau de la prise usb tisser
deuxième qui se situe ici vous avez donc
du son stéréo la qualité sympa ça
rajoute ali version et c'est vraiment
très bien on a donc un écran qui est top
on a donc de la puissance est donc bien
pour le multimédia le son est cool qu'en
est il maintenant de l'autonomie croyez
moi ils 60 ruquier assez énorme avec ce
smartphone vous avez une batterie de 4
me
san millan terreur franchement vous
tenez deux jours sans problème un jour
et demi si vous êtes vraiment vraiment
vraiment gourmand mais vous le pousse
dans ses retranchements mais deux jours
sans problème qui n'ont plus de ça ce
qui est cool c'est que vous avez de la
fast charge avait de la recharge rapide
40 watts en 30 minutes vous leurs
charges et aux trois quarts ça va très
vite c'est très pratique ça c'est
vraiment hyper hyper appréciable en
termes d'autonomie vous avez pas mal de
réglages directement dans vos paramètres
vous avez plusieurs modes mode
performance mode gestion d'alimentation
d'économie vous reste 28 eur mode de
gestion d'ultra et vous reste 128 heures
là vous voyez il me reste 54% batterie
il me reste 25 eur et franchement ya de
quoi faire il ya un autre point qui est
vraiment génial c'est la charge inversé
son fils c'est à dire que je vais
pouvoir utiliser mon smartphone pour
recharger à notre téléphone j'ai promis
si un iphone 10 r je le prends je le
mets derrière ça en train de le charger
vous avez l'icône là c'est à dire que
monbahus est en train de recharger mon
smartphone directement en étant collés
comme ça ça c'est vraiment génial c'est
assez dingue parce que votre smartphone
devient une power banques et pour
recharger n'importe quel appareil sans
fil un autre smartphone on peut aussi
chargé des écouteurs son filon pour
changer pas mal de choses et je trouve
que l'idée est vraiment bien parce que
elle apporte de la dominance hawaï c'est
à dire que ce mec 20 pro va dominer les
autres smartphones et vab donner de
l'autonomie parce que lui il en a à
gaver équivalent partager aux autres
cette techno je sais pas si elle servira
beaucoup ça servira beaucoup de monde
attend dans ce qui est sûr c'est que
c'est un super coûte comme c'est très
très bon pour l'image de la marque
mais là où on est complètement dans la
démesure est ce smartphone c'est au
niveau de la photo et de la vidéo
déjà le terrain pour aller loin alors
l'allumette 20 pro va carrément encore
plus loin vous avez donc un trip capteur
photo l'arrière 40 mégapixels c'est là
capteur principal avec une ouverture de
f 1.8 vous en avez un autre de 20
mégapixels 7 grand-angle couleurs qui
peut aussi faire de la super macro est
une ouverture de f 2.2 et vous avez le 8
méga pixels teintées l'objectif qui me
servira pour le mode portrait qu'il
ouvre à f 2.4 et à l'avant vous avez une
caméra de 24 mégapixels
il ya tellement à dire sur cet appareil
photo que je peux pas vous le dire dans
cette vidéo je vais faire une deuxième
vidéo
parce que franchement c'est juste à lui
sinon ce que vous pouvez faire avec
c'est extrêmement complet vous avez la
photo la vidéo le mode trop vous avez
des plus avec tout ce que vous voulez
dans ralenti panoramique monochrome vous
une panne l'aps il ya pas mal pas mal de
choses panorama 3d hd aquatique enfin
c'est vraiment hyper hyper hyper complet
bien évidemment le mode portrait les
clichés nocturne et le mode ouverture
c'est tout simplement hallucinant vous
pouvez filmer jusqu en 4k vous avez de
l'intelligence artificielle ya pas mal
de choses vous pouvez régler
c'est vraiment un appareil qui est hyper
hyper hyper complet sur la photo
franchement c'est complètement
hallucinant on va nous faire une vidéo
spéciale photos vidéos sur ce match
d'impro parce que c'est tellement de
choses à dire vous avez du bluetooth 5
il est certifié ip 68 vous avez la
possibilité de mettre deux cartes sim
directement à l'intérieur et vous avez
une recherche comme vous le dis en usb
type c'est au niveau de l'eau est ce
vous avez eu est mu wayne white comme
vous voulez c'est la version 9 vous avez
android 9,5 je suis pas hyper hyper fun
de la surcouche de huawei c'est pas la
plus esthétique néanmoins il ya beaucoup
beaucoup d'options on peut faire
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de choses on
a également de la navigation par jef
dessus vous avez up vos petits gestes
fait un petit sac de côté vos revenus en
avant la navigation par ce geste le
multitâche on est donc sur un smartphone
qui complètement hallucinant
complètement optimisé une vraie bête de
compacter tranche mans à qui est destiné
aux smartphones parce que on est sur un
produit qui coûte 999 euros pourquoi
est-ce qu'on doit acheter ce smartphone
à 999 euros
tout simplement parce que pour moi un
des meilleurs produits de cette fin
d'année si ce n'est le meilleur en
termes de photos on va reparler c'est
juste hallucinant préfère avec que ce
soit au niveau de la performance au
niveau de l'autonomie au niveau de
toutes les options vous avez dessus la
recharge rapide l'écran incurvé oled
fins et il est extrêmement complet et je
trouve que 999 euros
il vaut son prix alors c'est un budget
c'est un bon budget ça coûte cher mais
je trouve que il est vraiment
extrêmement bien réussi on va tester
d'ici quelques jours le mec 20 khz et
son petit frère on regarde les vins
light qui est le tout petit frère on va
tester le le may devant tout cas pour
voir un petit peu ce qui nous apporte et
comment se positionne par rapport au
match d'impro mais en attendant je
trouve que acheter ce vin procès
vraiment pas se tromper c'est un
excellent smartphone sur android très
puissant vraiment bien attention à la
solidité
je ne veux pas faire de crash test je
vais pas le jeter mais j'ai un peu peur
je trouve vraiment glissant protéger le
prenais vraiment une coque de protection
ça serait vraiment dommage de l'abîmé
surtout à ce prix là bon et maintenant
ça vous de me dire ce que vous en pensez
comment on le trouvait ce mec 20 pro est
ce que vous l'avez déjà testé est ce que
vous l'avez peut-être déjà acheté est-ce
que vous avez un projet de lâcheté est
ce que vous trouvez qu'il écoulait ce
que vous trouvez que huawei a vraiment
fait un excellent boulot dessus et
comment vous le trouvez par rapport aux
autres produits du marché je pense
notamment à un google pixels 3 ou un
google pixels 3xl je pense un one + 6 t
je pense à un iphone 10 aces 1 il faut
10 s max je pense à un iphone dit certes
marqué moi tout ça en commentaire et
puis dites moi vraiment si ce produit
pourrait vous intéresser
je vous invite à venir visionner ma
playlist kelly à tous mes tests de
smartphones ça pourra vous aider un
petit peu à dégrossir tous à vous y
retrouver puis savoir quel smartphone
choisir fin 2018 vous allez voir
franchement sans voix du bois je ferai
d'autres vidéos pour parler de ce
produit dont vous invite à faire une
seule chose c'est à vous abonner et à
rester connectés d'ici là soyez sages